hi
i'm jan at microsoft translator and in
this short video i'm going to walk you
through adding the microsoft translator
widget to your tumblr
so that it can be read by people all
over the world i'll let you know
up front that this will involve a little
bit of coding but whether you know how
to code or not the steps are all pretty
easy
let's get started here's my tumblr
dashboard
first i need to get the code snippet to
install the translator widget on my page
i'll open up a new tab and go to
dot www.microsofttranslator.com slash
widget here
i can look through all the different
options of how to customize the widget
for my page
i can change the website language in
case i write my posts in a language
other than english
i can change the color of the widget so
that it will look better on a dark or
light background
and i can let other people suggest
alternative translations to the ones
provided by microsoft translator
i'm fine with the defaults here so next
i'll just copy all of the code in the
grey box
and go back to tumblr from my dashboard
i'll click on customize which will take
me to my customization screen
now i need to add the code that i just
copied from the translator widget site
to my tumblr's code
up here in the left under the name of my
tumblr theme
you'll see it says edit html
when i click on it it shows me all of
the code i just need to find the right
place to add it
every tumbler theme is going to be a
little bit different
but as a general rule the best place to
add the widget code is just before the
body tag
to find this press ctrl f to search the
code
and then type in the less than sign
and the word body this should highlight
the body tag
in the code now you can just paste the
widget snippet right after the next
greater than sign most of the time this
will be right after the word body
now press update preview save
and exit out of the customization screen
now when you reopen your blog the
translator widget will appear at the top
of the page
i'll just test it out here quickly
here's my tumblr in spanish
french and arabic
there are a few things you'll want to
keep in mind first
the theme that you've chosen may
slightly affect the way the widget looks
in most cases the widget will still work
the same but if you don't like the way
that it looks
you may want to change your theme also
there are some themes that may not let
you use the widget
for instance some themes may place an
overlay above the widget
which makes it so that you can't click
it
next you don't necessarily need to add
the widget snippet right below the body
tag
if you know how to code or just want to
play around you can add it wherever you
want
what you've done here is create a custom
themed tumbler
if you ever switch to another theme
you'll have to reinstall the widget
this also helps in case you put the code
somewhere that the widget doesn't quite
look right
you can just reapply the original theme
and will look just like it did before
you added the widget code
lastly just a note the widget will only
work on text that is typed into your
tumblr posts
it won't translate anything that is
contained within an image
thanks for watching this video you
should now be able to add the microsoft
translator widget to your tumblr
so that can be read by people around the
globe
if you need more information about
microsoft translator and the widget
you can find it at www.microsoft.com
translator thanks again